dia gérald brice viret attends je le
rappelle de suite il doit s'inquiéter
dois dire qu'est ce qui se passe à
l'antenne on va lui être inquiète pas tu
l'auras quand tu l'as vu ma chérie ça va
voter dis moi mon chéri ouais très bien
parce que je suis à l'antenne n'a en
fait c'est pour ça mon chéri si je suis
avec saïda c'est celle du haut dès
aujourd'hui vous voulez te faire un
groupe joue parce que c'est toi aussi
qui est responsable de tous ces dames
r600 ce jour gérard c'est chirac
voilà ces journées gérad mon chéri
fraîchement était vraiment un amour
farrakhan demain bah je sais mon tir et
tu pars à cannes demain à la valeur
vient de le faire on peut parfois on
vient de le faire pour bien le faire
dira gérard juste mon chéri tu risque
d'aller à cannes de mon chéri alors
avons va très bien on voulait sauter un
bon séjour au moins il te dira encore
merci pour le duo des monts gérald amour
et alors ces postulants brave tulle en
brèche tu l'envoies si tu le vois là bas
à cannes 1
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
roudet qua non parce que tu tues tu l'as
vu l'année dernière
mais depuis la série
ban a dit qu'elle dormait avec toi tous
les soirs et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je
crois qu'elle l'a vu elle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai regardé leader qui veut dire tu as
pas le voir à cames donc centrale c'est
ça c'est pas moi c'est pas moi autant
massa lui maudore a salué ben voilà
c'est fait mieux moi je pense à l'arrêt
donc ce soir je ne rendrai pas l'antenne
si on n'a pas fait un tu l'as vu mon cul
concluant et jackie quartz à qui ses
filles à malaussanne des rois c'est qui
vous voulez